[Music]
this morning on the dish the man behind
an empire of Seattle area restaurants
born in Delaware Tom Douglas only moved
to Seattle as a young adult and despite
no formal training became a driving
force in defining the cuisine of the
Pacific Northwest a few years after
getting his first restaurant job he
opened dahlia lounge soon becoming the
epicenter of Seattle's local sustainable
and organic food movement in 1/m the
James Beard Award as Best Chef in the
northwest one of three Beard Awards to
his credit he went on to open another 17
restaurants and his own farm to supply
them with fresh produce chef Tom Douglas
welcome to the dish
thanks so much awesome to be here
awesome to have you did you bring us you
brought incredible stuff but tell them
what's here bringing food to the New
York City is what a great restaurant
town but I brought you a classic
Northwest barbecue dinner yeah I just
love you know in our town if you don't
have salmon on the barbecue you don't
have a barbecue yeah and so we have the
baby back spareribs there we've got a
big beautiful wild king salmon that's
been charcoal grilled over here we have
a chop salad I like taking this time of
year right all the different produce is
starting to hit the stands and I like
taking it all mixing it up in front we
have beautiful corn on the cob and in
your glasses we have this lovely color
yeah right that's a little rhubarb
mimosa and in the northwest we're
blessed with almost a thousand wineries
including the st. Michelle winery group
and this is their sparkling wine mixed
with a little bit of rhubarb syrup and
the finish we have a veritable buffet on
your under-strength day great
we've got salted caramel whip we've got
strawberries or blueberries that are out
right now toasted almonds and a
delicious buttermilk shortcake what's
not to love there chef 18 restaurants I
mean how does a man go from no formal
training to 18 restaurants well you know
it's all about the team right yeah of
course you can't do it yourself
you're married to a chef you know you
know that it takes a brigade
it takes a brigade right of people and
so that's how you end up doing it our
motto and our company is delicious
to serve with graciousness every day
right get up and show up and be present
and so that's what we do and that's what
comes across in our restaurant so
whether it's the humble pizzeria or it's
the fanciest of that we have like the
Dahlia lounge so that's that's what we
try to do this one dressing because you
were self-taught you had no formal
culinary training so first well let's
start where did your love of food come
from well grandma's you know that's kind
of a classic scenario though but I I
remember clearly coming down into the
kitchen when grandma was visiting and
she would have the German schnecken or a
cinnamon roll pull apart kind of rolled
out on the kitchen table on towels right
and then I just begged to help and she'd
let me spread the butter or sprinkle the
cinnamon sugar and then we'd roll him up
with that good toasty warm yeast dough
and that smell to this day when I make
snakin I can really you know
visualize and have the whole process in
my head and then of course from there my
interest was piqued went to home at
class in high school mainly to meet
girls turned out good but at the same
time I was the only guy and you know in
the moment very awesome and I really
kind of fell for it not only the girls
but the cooking right I fell for it
enough that I would bring the food from
class to my football practice is a very
bad idea because the first thing we made
was cream puffs right is a classic cream
puffs on the football field I think what
my nickname was not good how did you
develop the confidence to open your own
restaurant I mean and in the self-taught
you know vein that we were talking about
how did you teach yourself well nobody's
ever really self-taught in my mind you
have mentors you have you have role
models that you look up to and you learn
from I mean I was surrounded by people
like the Nordstrom family about you know
talk about service models right they are
the king of service the Starbucks
company which was you know taught me how
to treat part-time employees in the best
way possible so I gleaned from everyone
I worked around and then of course every
cook I ever cooked next to I learned
something from every immigrant that came
through our kitchen
I learned something from and whether it
was being on the with Julia Child or on
the Martha Stewart Show or wherever I
have been writing my posts or on the
dish you learned something and so I
think that's more the thing about my
career and then of course I'm not an
entrepreneur so when I make money I like
to build a new restaurant well that you
have done little unsettled that way chef
as I ask you to sign this dish and
custom on the program I'll ask you if
you could share this surf-and-turf
delicious seasonal organic Seattle
bounty with anyone past or present who
would it be
Oh totally in the present I'm a big fan
of Michelle and Barack Obama and cooked
for them many times and so I would love
to invite them to dinner and to have a
conversation about their years in the
White House and how exhilarating it must
have been if I could be a politician I
want to be President go home chef Tom
Douglas great to see you thanks you too
and for more on Tom Douglas and the dish
head to our website at CBS this morning
calm